salut aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler
de trois anecdotes trois anecdotes
historiques qui en fait sont sûrement
des légendes urbaines ces trois
anecdotes qu'on les a raconté j'ai
beaucoup aimé quand je verrai un compte
à mon tour j'aime beaucoup mais j'ai
fait énormément de recherches sur le
sujet et rien ne prouve que ça s'est
vraiment passé ce qui n'empêche qu'elles
sont intéressantes qu'elles sont
stimulantes aussi pour la manière de
penser et c'est un petit peu comme une
friandise pour le cerveau la première
anecdote elle concerne picasso picasso
quand il a eu son heure de gloire quand
il allait au restaurant ils ne paient
pas son repas et ils paient en laissant
un petit dessin sur l'anah et il ya une
histoire qui raconte on ne sait pas si
ça s'est vraiment passé ou pas en tout
cas on en a pas la preuve mais une
histoire amusante qui raconte qu'un jour
il fait pareil son petit dessin sur la
nappe comme d'habitude le restaurateur
vient le voir et 10 mètres c'est
formidable merci beaucoup
ça servira à payer la note y'a pas de
problème
est-ce que vous pouvez juste mais le
signer avant de partir et picasso aurait
répondu non je vais pas signer le dessin
je veux juste payer ma note pas acheter
le restaurant c'est énorme
il y en a une deuxième avec picasso où
il ya deux versions d'ailleurs de
l'histoire va vous raconter celle avec
un industriel
un jour un industriel commandes à
picasso une espèce de logo une sorte de
logo pour sa société et picasso demande
des milliers de francs en avance et un
mois passent deux mois passent trois
mois passés et admettons cinq ou six
mois passent et l'industriel n'a
toujours pas de nouvelles de picasso
alors qu'il a versé beaucoup d'argent
donc il va chez picasso pousser sa
petite gueulante
il a une chez picasso il explique son
problème kick-ass haut et un petit peu
saoulé il prend une feuille un crayon et
il fait un super logo comme ça en
quelques secondes et lui donne il fait
tenez voici votre logo l'industrie elle
lui dit attendez j'ai attendu cinq mois
alors qu'il vous fallait cinq secondes
pour faire ça et picasso aurait répondu
non il m'a fallu toute une vie plus 5
secondes pour faire ça ça fait partie
également de mes histoires préférées
mais dans toutes les histoires que je
connais dance floor il y en a une qui
est vraiment de loin ma préférée
j'espère qu'elle s'est passé j'espère
sincèrement qu'elle s'est passé elle
concerne einstein
quand einstein a commencé à être célèbre
avec sa théorie sur la relativité il a
fait une tournée de conférences aux
états unis toutes les universités
voulait kaïn stein viennent faire sa
conférence avec un petit débat après on
qu'il a fait sa tournée en commençant
par princeton et en finissant par
stanford et il avait un chauffeur avec
lui son chauffeur attitré qui a fait
toute la tournée des états unis avec lui
et son chauffeur assister à chaque
conférence
à chaque fois il suivait einstein et il
écoutait tous les questions réponses à
la fin et c est un jour le chauffeur dit
einstein écouter juste tellement bien
suivi pour conférences jeux pourraient
la faire à votre place sans problème
j'en suis sûr et einstein qui a la
réputation d'être malicieux lui aurait
répondu ah bon c'est quoi la prochaine
date où est ce qu'on va aujourd'hui le
chauffeur dit on va à stanford et
einstein me dis ok alors pour stanford
vous mettais mon costume je mets le
vôtre et c'est vous qui faites la
conférence et c'est vraiment ce qui se
passe c'est à dire que le chauffeur
d'einstein fait toute la conférence
devant tous les universitaires
il gère le truc nickel à la perfection
puis à la fin de l'exposition va dire
vient le temps des questions réponses où
les gens posent des questions et le
maître de conférence doit répondre sauf
que là c'est le chauffeur il s'en sort
plutôt pas mal puisque d'une université
à l'autre c'est à peu près le même
question qui était posée est un des
universitaires pose une question très
pointue très complexe pour le chauffeur
c'est la galère et c'est là que le
chauffeur est extrêmement mal hein il
garde son sang froid et dit écoutez je
suis assez étonné vous me posiez cette
question
c'est tellement simple que c'est mon
chauffeur qui va vous répondre et le
chauffeur monte sur l'estrade prend le
micro répond à la perfection puisque
c'était einstein
alors oui ce sont des légendes urbaines
puisqu'on ne sait pas si ça s'est
vraiment passé et si ça s'est passé est
ce que ça s'est passé exactement comme
ça ça n'empêche pas que ces histoires
sont intéressantes parce qu'il ya
toujours une petite leçon à en tirer est
en tout cas quand je dis que c'est un
bon pour le cerveau parce qu'à chaque
fois à chaque finalité de ces histoires
ont fait ok c'est cool c'est ce qu'on
appelle un twist je connais beaucoup
comme ça des biens jeux en dur ben sur
des personnes célèbres sur des faits
historiques
vous en connaissez sûrement aussi c'est
une de mes passions de lire ça donc si
vous en connaissez vous les mettez dans
les commentaires et je dirais ça donnera
sûrement que je connais déjà mais
j'espère en à prendre des nouvelles il
ya une nouvelle fonctionnalité
maintenant on peut épingler des
commentaires donc d'ici 24 heures
l'anecdote que je connaissais pas et que
j'aurais trouvé la plus amusante la plus
passionnante à lire je les peins glory
en top com merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo jusque là j'espère que ça vous a
plu d'écouter ça c'était un truc un peu
plus léger dans le milieu de la semaine
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait si ça vous tente et
le mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an depuis le 1er janvier
jusqu'au 31 décembre qui frappent à la
porte là il arrive très très très vite
rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao ciao
[Musique]
dallas